para eeuu a las fuerzas israelíes e
probablemente fueron responsables del
asesinato de chirín aa bucle aunque la
experiencia sobre el origen de la bala
arrojaron resultados no concluyentes un
análisis forense independiente
supervisado por la oficina del
coordinador de seguridad de eeuu
determinó que el proyectil que alcanzó a
la periodista palestino en
estadounidense estaba muy dañado y que
por eso no hubieron conclusiones claras
pero el departamento de estado señaló
que tras analizar las investigaciones de
palestinas e israelíes se concluyó que
es probable que las fuerzas de defensa
de israel mataran agua que el 11 de mayo
pasado en jenín pero no de manera
intencional sino como consecuencia
trágica del operativo que realizaban en
el lugar
esta postura de washington se ajusta a
otras investigaciones de medios
estadounidenses de la autoridad
palestina y también a las versiones de
testigos que apunta apuntan a la
culpabilidad de las fuerzas israelíes
pero a la vez es lo suficientemente
ambigua para que israel mantenga su
tesis de que no es posible determinar
con certeza el origen del disparo que
mató a agua y esta pesquisa coordinada
por eeuu fue posible después de que
durante el fin de semana la autoridad
palestina aceptara entregar a la bala
con la condición de que no cayera en
manos de israelí a partir de ahí se
dispararon varias versiones desde que
oficiales israelíes presenciaron este
estudio hasta que fueron quienes se
hicieron cargo de la investigación los
familiares de agua que por su parte
cuestionaron la falta de transparencia
del procedimiento y se mostraron
incrédulos al resultado que calificaron
de frío consuelo e insultante para la
memoria de shiring por considerar que
ignora la brutalidad de la ocupación y
además acusaron a washington de
ajustarse a la postura de israel
cuestionado por demócratas y
republicanos el gobierno de joe biden se
apuró en zanjar esta investigación antes
de que el presidente estadounidense
viaje a medio oriente un recorrido
previsto entre el 13 y el 16 de julio
próximos